putting things off it's what we humans
do we've put off dealing with global
warming for so long thankfully President
Obama has stopped putting things off
he's insisting on tough new fuel
efficiency standards for automobiles
built in America higher fuel efficiency
means a cleaner environment for our
children it means driving smart
eco-friendly cars so you'll always be
able to fit into that parking spot smart
car indeed unless of course you want to
survive a collision with anything larger
than a hot dog stand we're the
morticians Association of America and we
salute President Obama and his plans for
our environmental future we urge you to
follow the president's example since
more of you will reach your final
resting place sooner than you
anticipated don't put off planning for
your future contact your local
morticians Association of America member
today let trained professionals help you
work through the important decisions
cremation or burial headstone or
monument open or closed don't put off
planning for your final day it may be
here sooner than you think